i like comma specifically
because we're building something that
has never been built before so it's the
the new frontier it's space exploration
what's up oh yeah you're good okay take
three
my previous job i worked at a big
company and
if i saw something that i wanted to give
that specific team feedback on
it was quite difficult to to do so
just because how large the company was
with comma
if i want to tell somebody about
something within open pilot
or some other aspect
i can walk down to their office and just
talk with them directly
the two things that we look for
fundamentally are intelligence and
motivation
you know if i'm thinking about a company
i want to work for i want to work for a
company full of great people
right you got to make sure the bar stays
really high not just for who you hire
but also hopefully you keep around
i think we have the best chance at
solving self-driving cars because our
approach
involves actually shipping a product and
proving it out as we go it also allows
us to
become profitable and be you know
financially
responsible so we have thousands of
users every day that upload data
and we process those
drives that they upload most of them
within
seconds and all of them within like 10
minutes or something like that
everyone who has tackled the
self-driving car problem has done it
like the silly way where you try to like
you know put boxes around everything
um and then you uh take all those boxes
and try to like
figure out you know what the car ought
to do with some hard-coded algorithm
and like i feel like the whole lesson
that we all have learned in the research
community
is that you should just learn everything
you know learn it front to back
and that's exactly what we do just
waiting for this [ __ ] to install
you know we we have a whole stack that
teaches the car
um as closely as we can to just do what
a human would do
you know imitate the human driving
policy and that's
like what what makes comma really
special in the self-driving space is
just that we're doing the smart thing
to teach cars to drive themselves um
no no cone detectors here no cone
detectors
that's how we do it the people at comma
have a desire to work
harder i vibe off of that and i feed off
of that energy of others like
wanting to like just do everything they
can
and so that helps me kind of also
want to work harder self-driving is
going to be solved by
20 people and uh you know
a thousand computers
you